dans les trois mois qui vont venir nous
allons avoir cette situation de manque
de pluie qui va se poursuivre donc les
mesures que nous avons prises c'est
d'abord un certain nombre
d'interdictions
j'ai pris un arrêté pour interdire le
lavage particulier des voitures j'ai
pris un arrêté pour interdire le
remplissage ou le vidange âge des
piscines est également malheureusement
nous avons déjà pris un arrêté pour que
les agriculteurs du centre de l'île à
rose un jour sur deux il va falloir sans
doute aller plus loin et organisé avec
les collectivités locales avec les
opérateurs de l'eau une situation dite
de crise quotidienne jour après jour
tous les jours nous aurons le niveau de
production des opérateurs et nous
déciderons pour le jour suivant de
manière à ce que la population soit
prévenu des coupures d'eau alors quelle
ampleur on peut considérer que c'est
vraisemblablement 10% de la population
sera concerné chaque jour quelles sont
les régions principalement concerné
alors toute la martinique est concernée
mais bien sûr il ya comme d'habitude une
focalisation sur le centre de la
martinique et sur le sud
vous savez par exemple tout ce qui est
desservi par la rivière blanche
le lamantin saint joseph et toutes les
communes du sud
ça représente deux tiers de la
population et il faut dire à la
population d'adopter des comportements
citoyens vraiment de respecter
l'interdiction de lavage des véhicules
de respecter pour ceux qui en ont
l'interdiction de
remplir les piscines de d'avoir une
gestion mesurée de l'eau car cette
population là comme toute la martinique
sera confronté à des coupures d'eau
j'espère que si nous gérons
raisonnablement si les comportements
citoyens sont observés nous limiterons à
peu près une coupure par secteur